ladder with Crowder studios is protected
exclusively by Walther hopper
[Music]
look
how many subscribers you got in YouTube
sudden when you crossed over that 1
million mark
you are beautiful could have been the
next PewDiePie
[Music]
an Asian skank we gotcha for a lawyer
raised your profile too fast it wasn't
him not gay Jared it was you you
remember that night at South by
Southwest you told me it'd be a great
idea to crash chain Twitter's panel you
said it'd be a great idea a great idea
we were demonetized before that
broadcast even went wine so what happens
[ __ ] we go gets direct support from
youtuber what do I get
a one-way ticket to D monetization bill
you were my produce in that cage ed you
should have looked down for me a little
bit should have taken care of me just a
little bit so I wouldn't have had to do
those web-based security ads for the
short-end money I got you in the myspace
trending list you saw some clicks you
don't understand I could have had class
I could have been at DePaul I could have
been somebody instead of a mug club
salesman bump which let's face it not
gay Jared is what I am it was you not
gay Jerry
[Music]
okay okay
that's all YouTube couldn't find you
here
take this walk our PPS with extended mag
and Crimson Trace laser you're gonna
need it
that's a high quality item yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
with you that is the sound of the
weekend it's a Thursday live stream Jim
Norton and Ben Shapiro on Today Show
also today's show brought to you by
hoppers trim it all I blew my back when
I blew him back and I have a ruptured
disk and I didn't warm up properly today
doing deadlifts was so loud that the guy
who cried Jim heard a popular you hurt
your back I said yeah it's funny
leave me in video studio as always as
Jaron who is now gay follow him on
Twitter at not gay Jared me at s Crowder
with your thoughts your comments your
photo shops I'm a meme now no big deal I
fulfill my legal obligations during
conclusions are we good I'm not a meme
it's my goal and at G Morgan G but you
took the picture and I just eat him up
for new still look it simplified we're
not gonna hire you jail what's one of
the day done well we've got the lorenz
Perrier like just a little baby bottle
here for ya hey fan computer with the
overlays ready no seriously hopper I've
found this how to ask the vet an
armistice at the CVS is it yeah it's the
same paint it seems like it's the same
paint does it cost less I don't know but
these pills expired in like 2016 which
is a good thing it's a good it's a good
thing because it shows that I'm not an
addict I don't know if it's an opiate or
opioid watch your rock you start but the
bad thing is I took that it's very years
ago most to your point the latter most
comedians cannot claim they have that
you know two year old pills wolf of
wallstreet is gonna hit you a question
of the day is do you think we're going
to talk about this obviously in light of
the West Virginia story do you think
public schoolteachers are woefully
underpaid that seems to be the the
acceptance among society today I
disagree all right why are you laughing
because that statement is so hilarious
all we do is pay them more you don't
deserve it in the world is teaching I'd
say killing bin Laden news of the day
McDonald's is flipping its trademark
arches upside down to honor women on
hashtag International Women's Day
really McDonald will flip its logo
upside down to form a W on all digital
channels including its Instagram and
Twitter feeds and a hunter restaurants
will have special packaging crew shirts
and hats and bag stuffers for honest so
grab them by the gold
arches and jumping on the feminist
bandwagon of course Wendy herself will
also be going topless oh you know
Chipotle just shamelessly released a
taco bowl with 50% less Listeria that's
almost tasteless and not related to
women's day I don't know who's gonna go
over well off for feminists because I
think that I think McDonald's is half
the reason they're gelatinous and single
so I don't think they're gonna buy ounce
that now by the way with the W consent
in there they're not gonna buy it
because they've already bought a lot of
it 1 billion served that could read okay
800 million feminists served the rest is
a take a guess but a world by way this
was fascinating every now and then you
get a story that's just a fill the
world's oldest message in a bottle was
found by a beach walker in Australia
comes from The Guardian the bottle have
been thrown overboard from a German
sailing ship in 1886 Wow across the
Indian Ocean there did you know this
this come from a German story spin
computer I don't think so that's why you
don't get to plug your Twitter he's not
even ready want to go luckily the
discovery of the message in a bottle was
caught on tape
[Applause]
it's the international language the
universe is telling you that if Trudeau
had collected that someone would be sued
yeah although I hate hit the
notification bell if you're watching on
YouTube because subscribing doesn't mean
anything anymore so if you want to be
notified of our videos and not have the
Google of Lord stop it you'll hit the
back a woman was arrested for attempted
I'm gonna talk about public school
teachers but this is a story that's more
important a woman was arrested for
attempting to trick Albuquerque
authorities yesterday when she claims
she had a prescription for medical
marijuana and suspicions were all but
confirmed when she informed them that
her copay would be toothless blopps it
can be speaking a bunch of new study
shows that marrying your first cousin is
not as bad as we thought it was
conducted over seven years by a data
scientist and Columbia University and it
shows that it's okay to marry your first
cousin as long as your children do not
marry their first cousins mmm yeah just
come up somewhere yeah yes third cousin
Andy oh by the way fun fact
20 states today still allow cousin
marriage and we'll talk about them West
Virginia is not amongst them that's
that's hilariously surprising it's the
forbidden fruit of theirs yes that's
where they do the lie really West
Virginia here's the thing now here's the
fun extra bump act as sexual
relationships with said cousin totally
permissible Hans if M can be there can
you fact check there's that true yes
that is true okay that is so sexual
relation allowed with your cousins in
Virginia but not married oh hey hey you
make an honest woman out of her you
divorce her
and bangin on the side that's what
separates us from the beasts of the sea
stringing her along would just be
indecent it would just
torchy commit don't you commit way the
fact that someone at Columbia took seven
years to study this is he to watch list
somewhere probably so they came back as
a peer-reviewed make it just can't be
two generations down he's got a first
cousin I liked her taking his rights
first and do passes later for him grab
my the golden arches Israel is in the
process by the way of building a Jewish
Disneyland oh good designed by rabbis
and it's as fun as it sounds
the very company high-tech it tech is
planning a theme park based on Jewish
values and it will feature Torah themed
rides Jewish cultural cuisine and a Fast
Pass Lane actually for patrons to [ __ ]
about rising ticket prices I have to see
the pass to Hershey Park about
eighty-five it sucks
how are you first by the way not a
country just so you know but always
trying to keep up this development is
prompted Palestine to break ground on
their new theme park six over Gaza Strip
yeah look at all the children having fun
and they're humans and they're human
shield that was almost immediate that
happened fast
firing an ak-47 we have Jim Norton will
be honest gonna be relaxed day because
am i doing what the pain pills by the
way I'm getting better or is that from
no one here who tomatoes Carter so
here's one thing I wanted to talk about
today we've talked about it on the show
but haven't really gotten in depth I
know I'm gonna get some flack for this
us place the question of the day many
people have the idea in their head that
schoolteachers are severely underpaid
public servants where do they get that
month here is the fact that teachers are
just going to have to keep accepting
lower salaries despite the importance of
our job of their job but we as a society
of decided that teaching is not that
important it's only because we make that
decision we're the taxpayers we're the
ones who decide how much the teachers
get and we won't pay them not only don't
we pay teachers what they deserve to be
paid in other countries that have better
test scores than ours you hear about
that all the time actually teachers get
paid much more on an even standard with
professionals or engineers and in other
walks of life although some do tell you
my sister by the way how's your brother
teaching actually pays pretty you're the
truth they actually paid pretty well and
so one thing I know it's unpopular
scipios it's the most important job no
not really
it's really not by the way you know are
we paying are we paying Eloy Clinton's
hairstylist on a curve what is going on
it just seems like you go back in
history like oh it was always bad yeah
he's never changed wasn't ladies they go
through that crossover age I was like
I'm just gonna cut it short now and do
this sort of flock of seagulls she's
always done that it's like Taco Bell to
keep revamping it but it still just says
the same exact thing yeah so teachers
are actually paid well let me lay the
case up for you no I'm not saying the
teachers too aren't important they
shouldn't be paid what they're worth
that is not what I'm saying
hold your comments let's compare them
first to other government workers school
jobs okay some of the better paying ones
out there see this first chart from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics they received
more than two times the benefits of
employees in the private sector by the
way the average public school teacher
comes to us I think national view more
than double the benefits package
received by typical workers well private
sector so when we take the benefits into
account overall compensation is actually
higher than private sector teachers
which listen shouldn't surprise you
obviously yeah public dole they're gonna
be paid more than private teachers yeah
they don't do better by the way test
scores aren't better now well here's
something we haven't even
yet we've compared to the other
government workers to private private
school teachers they only make nine they
only worked nine months out of the year
yeah yeah there's only thing nobody
talks when we talk about what they're
paid so the average salary for a public
school teacher is about fifty-seven
thousand dollars okay not nothing that's
a lot
no it's but if we prorate that for
working twelve months not even clued in
the benefits by the way instead of nine
teachers will be making seventy six
thousand dollars seventy six thousand
dollars well above the average salary by
the way for workers with a college
degree so if we're gonna do that because
I don't want it well you can't these
people they go to college okay let's not
just compare them to McDonald's worked
or 5 or 15 it is higher than the average
college degree worker and in line with
the median salary for workers with
master's degrees or higher she's seventy
seven thousand dollars by the way
something else it doesn't matter what
your test scores are doesn't matter how
your students are doing you're paid that
amount and they're nearly impossible to
fire even if they suck you'd have to be
given the Kevin Spacey treatment to your
students time yes I for them to even
consider getting you out of a rubber
room and then it'll take you about a
year and a half to two years to go yes
yeah well you're gonna say something
yeah so I I think it's it's just
absolutely seen I had never heard that
clip by the way that you played at the
beginning when they were saying the
teachers just accept lower and lower pay
lower pay like I just I just laughed out
loud because I'm like I didn't even know
that was out there in the narrative
okay listen so here's what's gonna
happen this year we're not I know you
were expecting a 12% we're gonna give
you a two-and-a-half percent raise this
year you're cutting our pay yeah it's
actually called the race and every
single time that this this argument
comes up to like it's for the children
it's for the children
our scores are terrible we do nothing
but throw money at the problem we spend
what we're like ranked fifth in the
world and spending per student 40% more
than other OECD countries out there and
you're telling me that you need to raise
teachers and you still suck are you
serious where else listen I'm sorry that
the overlays were not prepared I'm sorry
the sketches were edited but um I feel I
can't fire me just what was it waiting
for Superman was the film about and they
talked about in New York right so yeah a
long time ago this filmmaker was a
leftist but was a lipstick lad and they
jumped all over the film
because it showed kind of corruption of
teachers unions yeah by the way once
about money in politics I always talk
about big oil Koch brothers not even
close to the money being bandied about
by public sector unions yeah Jews are a
big one in it I'm some thing which
bumper stickers you see all the time I
know I've talked about this ad nauseam
this idea that we're spending more on
the military than tits like this paltry
sum that's left them no actually our
total spending on education is 946
billion dollars annually compared to
eight hundred and thirty five billion
for military including by the way
veteran care ok so it's important to
note that just the bumper sticker
doesn't necessarily it's not accurate
no they're skewing the step because
eighty-five percent roughly comes from
state and local governments not federal
by the way all of your parents people
watching they all went to school before
there was a National Department of
Education there okay and the test scores
are fine
some would say they're almost easier to
employ than Malloy yeah you want to see
the pay rate pay rate go for teachers
get rid of public education
tomorrow complicate completely get rid
of it well get rid of no get rid of the
federal Department of Education but it
states no get the state's out of it sell
all the land let private companies come
in have a base for people who can't
afford to go and watch how people can
now instead of paying property tax that
goes towards it okay so you're talking
out of school like I scrolled out your
program
no I'm saying get rid of the schools
yeah yeah yeah well so they can't yeah
exactly so the poor poor family even
there though you don't have to go that's
you don't even go that far you can still
keep public education in the states
allow them to do it and give the kids a
voucher so they can take it to at least
but right now we have an educational
system where you have no choice
whatsoever you have it just depends on
your zoning district teachers can't be
fired and our test scores suck and we're
spending more on this than our nuclear
arsenal
by the way our military up also needs to
it needs to hold up the star wars
defense system for Canada the Germans
aren't that what are the Germans given
the knate knate Oh aren't they skimping
on the bill there don't they owe more
than they've been paying no comment yeah
comment when it comes to plug in his
social media that's right when it comes
to shaming his country and rightfully so
nothing all right so according to CNN
actually West Virginia now they ranked
there this is the big
havelis for the story because I just got
a 5% raise okay
West Virginia is a great example this is
in the news recently they ranked 48th in
the nation in terms of how much they pay
their teachers so people go well okay
they're long overdue until you realize
they ranked 51st in SAT scores which
when I first read it I thought that must
be a typo no there are marvelous where
else do you rank below the number of
Rights and it's legit West Virginia they
ranked 48th in terms of 51st for SAT
scores so I actually say that's pretty
generous in any case here to discuss it
with us is Jed our West Virginia
Teachers Union correspondent Jed can you
hear us yes yes sure I can hear you
great okay so Jed so what do you say to
the skeptics out there critics who say
the 5% raise was unwarranted considering
your state already is 48 for pay but
51st for SAT scores that's huge that's
that dead last Jed if you work all right
no no say I'm afraid you're mistaken
Stephen if you do the arithmetic now
hold on
if you Adams together you got the 48 and
/ - 51 even that's not things Jed I
think oh no hold on hold on together now
if you put in together uh and you you
subtract the numbers supposed to be uh
you realize the disparity wage gap
painting of thanks Stephen I'm afraid
you're mistaken okay how's that well now
hold on hold on I am 45 46 and together
yeah two hundred forty six thousand
hundred Stephen which is pretty much
what I figured
I don't know paid and dimes yeah no I'm
entirely positive that's wrong well it's
not my fault my phone didn't do the flop
there's been no update there's not been
an absolutely been an update David I
don't get it not at all not even close
no I've taken afraid you're mistaken
okay Jed so listen you're ranked dead
last your schools are strained budget
wise as it is so you and your fellow
teachers are getting erased logic says
that the money's got to come from
somewhere do you know what they're going
to be cutting to make up for it or where
do you think they should that's all you
care about Stephen as cuts cuts cuts cuz
we don't need any more cuts the day our
air for C to host a bake sale the fun
enable tschappat teachers get the bunny
they deserve French you'll be a bright
day for our American Alison
oh good good what's out I'm gonna get my
home and leave
okay Jed our West Virginia's teachers
union correspondent will be up after
this with Ben Shapiro more pleasant
[Music]
now like any commercial break this
announcement is for fans of the louder
with Crowder program the viewers
listeners and downloaders joined under
the umbrella of comedy I hope a lot of
you guys and gals were listening out
there because I have something I want
you to do for me
March 22nd at SMU 7:00 p.m. at the
McFarland auditorium Lada was crowded
we'll be broadcasting live I know I know
it's murder asking you to leave your
computers and smart devices for a live
show in 2018 and certainly a show this
high-energy is no cakewalk
although it shouldn't be too tough to
attend for those who live in the Texas
area but remember this all the leftist
social justice warriors and professional
protesters in Texas are already trying
to stop this show from happening they
tried to run us out in a rail last time
at SMU and now we're offering you a
chance to rub it in their face and fill
up their whole damn theater with
laughter which is the nicest gift you'll
ever get from a nicest live show you'll
ever see oh and they won't know what to
do with themselves because what do you
do with an anti-fur when he won't stop
being an anti fur it seems this campus
really would enjoy laughing at 1 & 2 & 3
& 4 small an tyfa
so remember now your objective is SMU
seven o'clock on March 22nd that's March
22nd at McFarland auditorium doors open
at 6:00 synchronize your watches guys
and gals for operation louder with
Crowder glad to have our next guest his
parents the son of permission slip for
him to be on the show
you know his show at daily wire.com just
because he's like he has to have it
everywhere he has to be gaudy about it
it's called the Ben Shapiro show unlike
with me some people think my first name
is louder you can follow them on the
Twitter you know who spoilers this show
Ben Shapiro how are you sir I'm doing
okay just as always when I watch you
dance I wonder what I've done with my
life yeah well I this is happening I
feel that way when I dance which I've
been told is actually the sign of a good
dancer his immediate regret followed by
comorbid tendencies where'd that from
Baryshnikov did you yes yes exactly
I've been studying I've been studying a
lot of I took a humanities course in
college so this is the speaking of
humanities Ben this week has just teed
up for you let me just say the names
noon Berg Cohn your thoughts okay why
don't we begin with the globalist [ __ ]
Gary Cohn who's finally out that we're
not calling the globe let's cut who's
Jewish
we'd never do such a thing no no no we
call the globalist because he likes free
trade and so he's out
there's just total staffing chaos inside
the administration which is not a shock
considering that sam nunn Berg was once
part of the Trump campaign like the the
top men scene from Raiders of the Lost
Ark was apparent like that guy actually
did the staffing at the Trump campaign
yes and then did it again at the Trump
White House so Gary Cohn being out is
actually it's less about Gary Cohn than
about the guy who is who's replacing him
whose name slips my mind at this point
Peter Navarro at schmuck who apparently
knows nothing about free trade knows
nothing about economics but it's firmly
kin
that if we increase the price on every
one of basic steel products that somehow
the smelters will come back to
Pittsburgh or something yes say this
sort of bizarre the sort of bizarre idea
that what we really need in America is
more people in really heavy gear
carrying around things like a scene out
of Zoolander and having big fiery chasms
beneath them like that we need it to
look like more or we need more more or
looking parts of America like this is
what's gonna restore I'm not entirely
convinced that that cone didn't shoot a
sequel a faceoff sequel with kevin
O'Leary when you see this still on
second kevin O'Leary worked for Donald
Trump who knew who knew him being out I
mean I've talked to people in the white
house moonless in the chaos inside the
White House is a very real thing
everybody in the White House basically
has a last will and testament written up
everybody knows that they could be gone
in any minute or they're thinking about
quitting at any minute because let's
face it Trump is not a good person to
work for
they turn over in this in this
administration's extremely high when you
start Trump the other day doing the
everyone wants to work here only the
best people like no one wants to fill
who wants to be communications director
Cermak Steven I can make you communicate
I'm sure she'd settle out of court
thank you missile trying back something
yeah exactly I could make you
communications director inside of a week
you just booked you on Fox and Friends
every morning for a week and you talk
about how awesome Trump is and you
becomes director and you'd last for
approximately two weeks until you said
something halfway intelligence at which
point you would be out on your ass only
decision be saline or silicone what
would I go for to ensure job security I
know I think here's the thing we we had
to really we talked about this the last
time you were on trumps bite is is his
bark is worse than his bite right his
policies were pretty good at toward the
end a year toward beginning of the year
yeah and then the shooting happened and
of course it was it was like we talked
about 64 the underwater backwards
backgammon where he was actually pushing
for some of this gun control legislation
now we don't really know and here we
have it this week with the tariffs and
the taxes this is something I've always
been against a lot of people don't
understand I think most state the
biggest partner in steel I think we have
in the United States or aluminum is
Canada yeah yes it's not China it's
Canada no I get over eleven on the list
yeah China's number 11 on the list yeah
it did
the notion that we're being screwed by
Chinese steel is just not true
70% of all steel consumed in the United
States is created in the United States
the steel industry produced 5% more than
they did last year the year before so
meaning that it's actually growing the
steel industry in the United States the
stock price at companies like Nucor was
like 10 bucks at 2000 in 2000 now it's
like 62 dollars the United States have
been producing approximately the same
amount of steel since 1983
it's just that only 25% the same number
of employees are required to produce
that amount of steel because technology
is what's taking away the jobs not
competition from foreign sources so none
of this makes any sense for every job in
the steel industry there are at least 40
jobs that are dependent on products from
the steel industry meaning that if you
increase tariffs which increase prices
in the steel industry they're passing
those prices on to a bevy of other
industries and I'm sorry watching
billionaire Wilbur Ross on national
television holding up a Campbell's soup
can to explain to the poor why it is
that it doesn't matter that depending a
little bit more for their canned soup is
not real good press a you steel I
thought that was tin steel plate at
Enright corrode right I don't know
exactly either way someone yeah it's
either way there's BPA and someone's
gettin some cancer if it's Campbell's
soup from what I understand least a
little apparent I just need to buy my
oregano oil you'll be all good let me
ask you this there is there is some
inconsistency here because I understand
some people support this idea because
they feel as though as we've been
screwed on free trade now here there is
some truth to the kernel of truth right
a good example as I talked about this
with Ronald Reagan the least president
the least conservative thing he did was
the Harley Davidson fiasco the reason
Americans wanted Japanese bikes at that
time was because they were better anyone
go back to the AMF days it just just
awful awful awful motorcycles and the
protectionism actually hurt the consumer
because we wanted to preserve an
American company that should have gone
bankrupt
some people don't care be American buy
American so let's put that aside because
I know we're not gonna get everyone to
agree I think everyone has to agree that
there is a while-- this is how I feel
about this there's a wildly inconsistent
message this week either the economy is
rip-roaring and it's booming and we're
doing fantastically and we can't take
enough winning or we're getting screwed
by foreign competitors and we need to
batten down the hatches it seems like
there are some mixed signals I'm first
roar and I think this is one of the
problems for Trump is that he doesn't
care about the numbers he's not
interested in the numbers and you can
see that cuz the stock market has been
down
since these announcements about the
tariffs the markets are I've been thrown
into turmoil all the good that was done
by the tax cuts could easily be taken
away through a trade war I think it's
more about Trump has this vision in his
head of 1956 America when we were just
making assembly line trucks in and we
were making our own steel in Pittsburgh
and in Gary Indiana and never mind the
fact that this guy was like purple
because of all of that's being tossed
into the air in the production of that
he'll never find that mind the fact that
the Pittsburgh unemployment rate today
is 4.6 percent significantly lower than
it was during those days and the air is
breathable in Pittsburgh because
everybody is now in the health care
industry or the service industry right
it Trump has this this it's why I think
honestly there's such a gap in the
feelings about Trump between people who
are 60 and up and people who are 40
under people who are 40 and under look
at this and I go what are you even
talking about like you're talking about
the steel industry as though as the
steel industry goes so goes America I
don't know anybody who actually works in
the steel industry I know people in the
car industry I know people in the
service industry and then they're bunch
of people who are over 60 and they
remember working at a plant for 40 years
and getting their gold watch for
retirement and they're thinking well
finish till those days that would
actually fix everything
the interesting point I'd like to stay
on that for a second because I was just
watching driving miss daisy' other night
with my with my wife was a grandfather's
favorite film also by the way it was
amazing man Fred Corazon he was City he
was mayor they call him city
commissioner from Bloomfield where Mitt
Romney was from professor PhD and was
Obama dear and world works just
incredible you go to the funeral you
look oh my god what am I doing with my
life history book film was Driving Miss
Daisy so it was an emotional roller
coaster to watch with my wife because
she had never seen it but you know Danny
Aykroyd plays a plays one of one of your
folksy but in the South it's always
weird hearing a winn-dixie Jew very
horrible casting anyway but he walks
past the assembly line and you see these
people right here owns this big factory
just do you know it sounds like bullets
going off in this factory and you see
hundreds of people employed I'm going on
a second people talk about Halle Lenny
allow there's less job security than
ever and they feel like The Lost
Generation they've been abandoned I'm
gonna how many Millennials would spend
nine ten hours a day in one of those
factories because when we're talking
about the good old American days that's
what you're talking about was job
security that was Pittsburgh back then
with a lower unemployment rate
higher unemployment rate but how many
Millennials will be willing to do that
they benefit from the technology I think
there's a disconnect where when people
talk about it and you say this is what
job security means this kind of job back
then you'd hear money different tune
that's exactly right the same people who
decry the lack of job security are the
same people who are with Nancy Pelosi
when she says that we should ensure that
you don't have job lock that you
shouldn't be forced to actually be in a
job in order to have health insurance
right these are people who want to
switch jobs every couple of years or
they want to pursue their dreams of
being an artist but the notion that any
of them were gonna sit there and weld
right if they weren't well I come out
right now there are plenty of welding
jobs in the United States but can you
imagine any of these Gender Studies
majors actually welding talking about
the evils of capitalism in the lack of
job security and then they're majoring
in gender studies have you cared about
job security maybe you'd go into those
industries that are supposedly so
hallowed about job security again the
only reason that those assembly line
jobs were considered so awesome in 1930
is because assembly line jobs in 1830
we're even worse
meaning that the jobs now are better
than the jobs then you'd want to work
them more than you'd want like we laugh
at people who are baristas at Starbucks
that's a better job it is better to be
able reached at Starbucks than it is to
be sitting on an assembly line ensuring
that stuff that people are now doing in
Vietnam is being done in the United
States like this this is just it's such
foolishness
oh you're more of a rivet guy yeah
exactly you gotta get a rivet Los
Angeles Jewish I can't rivet I'll ruin
my hands these these are the money this
and this of the money I play violin come
on keep the hands
I sneak or some journeys how much we
have to get going here pretty soon yeah
- ten minutes oh we've only been on for
ten minutes
you said nunberg have I been saying it
wrong this whole time I've been hearing
people a new single I think so i widen
maybe they're mixing up him and Evan
Newtons yeah there's there's there's
Devin Nunes noonas nanu mu and then
there's and then there's nanu nanu and
then there's yeah I think they're just
not gonna work here no more what is
what's your read on the nunberg
situation obviously because he came out
he's a crazy person I mean that guy's
crazy
yeah do you be crazy and he that's not a
shock he he actually called me one time
during the election cycles right
after he'd been fired from the Trump
campaign and he's crazy
so like that that was not a great shock
to expect another call from Emilia
shortly the part of the part my favorite
part is the part where Erin Burnett is
asking him if he's been day drinking and
he's like he's like gulping from the cup
and just got to imagine that there's
whiskey and for that to be absolutely
hilarious but Erin Burnett that that was
the one that really struck me was all
these other people like he's calling in
to Jake Tapper
how's Jake supposed to know that this
guy is a legitimate loony but if you're
sitting across from somebody you say to
them have you been drinking because I
smell alcohol on your breath then the
question becomes so why is he on your
show right and you do have to ask
yourself why it is like if let's say
that let's say Austin Goolsbee just
started showing up randomly to the Obama
administration guy he started randomly
showing up to TV shows looking drunk off
his ass do you think he makes the other
that night do you think that they're
just like you know what these great TV
exactly that's right no nobody nobody
loves me anywhere near a camera right
nunberg is apparently a representative
of a rather non sober administration so
it's okay to do that in the defense of
the media in the defense of Donald Trump
he had a teetotaler I don't think he's
ever touched a drop that's no that's
right but in but the attitude of the the
attitude obviously is less than sober
over at the over at the White House and
it was during the campaign and in
defense of the media I will say this it
is very difficult to distinguish people
who are crazy like they should be in a
loony bin crazy from people who are just
crazy in politics there are a guy who
are wandering around trying get himself
booked on morning shows let's say 2012
claiming that the President of the
United States was born in Kenya and
firing off tweets - like Kristen Stewart
and Robert Pattinson you might think
maybe that guy shouldn't be on TV but
then he wouldn't be President of the
United States would he so it's kind of
difficult - yeah he's a lesbian laughs I
don't follow that part I don't follow
that at all she's a lesbian let's keep
our options open yeah but that's like a
rough on Pattinson Robert Pattinson
Patterson I think you might be gay - I
don't know but I saw him in a movie a
film recently it was intriguing wouldn't
that be amazing if they wouldn't it be
amazing if they if they had a
relationship but now he's gay and she's
a lesbian it would be a lot about that
relation we almost it would almost be
like was a Daniel
back in the day or Rock Hudson or they
were all arranged but secretly they were
playing you know I'll find the coin with
Gomer pile
I also saw a film recently with Daniel
Radcliffe I thought they're trying to
get out of their roles Daniel Radcliffe
is so embarrassing Lee bad at doing
accent it's a stone called the jungle
then have you seen this film the jungle
with Daniel Radcliffe no
I still have no idea what accent he was
trying to do I was like huh okay so it's
clearly Russian then I go no no it's
Bolivian and then it turns out his dad
was a Jew in an internment camp in like
Poland
now I just don't know what to think all
I know is Harry Harry Potter sucks at
acting amazing I don't know how we ended
up here
I don't either let's just stick here I
mean you know anybody want to talk and
talk to monji I mean as long as we're
just talking I hadn't seen that I
haven't said the Jumanji I don't want to
ruin you know I want it is gonna leave
it there my childhood we do Oscars come
on how do we do not do Oscars dude
because I didn't Oscars for hours and I
am that's true you did do that and I
ditched you I did it's an unfortunate
moment in our relationship yet listen
fish senses that's all you got to do
fish sex you win an award a grinding
Nemo man was it Dory what's-her-nuts the
name of the other one Torian Marlin Dori
Dori she forgot it because of PTSD I I
haven't seen it's the only film I think
on there that in Lady Bird that I hadn't
seen but you have seen fish fish fish
sex also known as shape of water your
thoughts yeah SJW splash yeah it's the
it's the exact plot of splash except for
it's a black woman a gay man and a mute
and a mute woman
it's like run rescue a mean splash
pretty much that's exactly right
awesome went with splash and set it in
the 1960s it's the shape of water and
then everybody praises it and says it's
awesome so great one of it won the great
war movies of all time Dunkirk versus
SJW splash where do you think
Hollywood's gonna go I think with this
one I mean one thousand twenty-five
thousand six hundred gallons and then
they have sex with a fish it is really
just despicable we always said hey it's
a slippery slope where does it stop do
we get to interspecies - wolde it stops
it stops it Kurt I can Wald
tentacle attender
about cordite can walled and tentacle
porn that's where this ends well we we
it was really hard I mean knock a Jared
barely I mean I don't think his liver
even made it through after two and a
half hours the drinking game it was it
was the ester and what's funny is there
was a disconnect for honey I mean let's
face it not yet not gay Jared's
expiration date is is two minutes from
now I mean like electrocuted the guy you
beat it with sticks you like make him
drink to excess I wanna borrow I'm just
shocked the man's alive and the man that
the liver transplant list has already
been set up for not eight years it's
being held together by double-sided tape
and strings from Jim Henson's creature
it's cute it's not at all let me ask you
this do you think as it goes because
last time you said you know what Donald
Trump if he continues this could be a
two-term er after this week what do you
if do you think he he could right the
ship this has been a rough week obvious
well um I mean it always it's if trends
hold so so far there's been no trend
basically it's been a scatter plot is is
how his presidency has gone sure I'll
have a week that's an a and then it'll
have a week follow that that's a nap and
there's no continuous trend so for two
months there it seemed like okay maybe
this is under control maybe he's really
getting a hold of things and now it
seems like he's been isolated in the
West Wing so Jared navaja
are obviously sort of alienated from the
president at this point by John Kelly
John Kelly is apparently being ripped by
Anthony Sarah Moochie at the behest of
Donald Trump on national TV
he's lost a reporter he's lost hope
Hicks a lot of his security blankets are
gone and so he's sort of lashing out and
also identifying with people like Peter
Navarro so it's yeah Dave Navarro at sex
I think Dave Navarro would have been a
better choice at this point at this
point who's to know I would just I would
just appoint anyone like that ben
shapiro you want to jump all right come
on in you don't even like me just do
whatever i don't care if not not for not
for all but not for all the tea in China
my friend oh my gosh yeah I'm working
for that administration with like I have
a story to tell you after uh when we go
when we hit a break here and you'll like
to hear this off here but it is the Ben
Shapiro show show of course that daily
wire.com I'm still still fuzzy headed
from the Oscars and you can listen to
him on iTunes on the soundcloud all over
the place and he loves that quip
toothbrush we will talk with you soon
mr. Shapiro
[Laughter]
hello another was called a viewers
helper here don't forget the new
condition to the podcast on the go on
iTunes or SoundCloud on the audio you
can download it and you can listen it
[Music]
library time one live read per week
unlike ben shapiro with those damn
electric toothbrushes and never any how
a new person what he does have good
products it's nice they're less afraid
of him than they are of us listen thank
you so much every week we've gained so
many subscribers reason to change my
mind segments have done incredibly well
we are so grateful but like we've talked
about we employ fifteen people here a
lot of credit in youtube is not paying
us youtube is not paying the bills with
adi monetization so louder with credit
calm / mug club if you join us $69 if
your student veteran or active military
for the year you get this hand etched
mug and not only do you get you get our
show every single day you get morning
grinders what's not get Jared and
Courtney and Gerald Dorrie and you get
Mark Levin you get Roman millennial you
McGinnis you get Steve bass you get a
whole bunch of shows it's the if you
like the free content even if you don't
want to watch The Daily Show because you
want us in small doses I don't blame you
kind of like me with hopper stream at
all still this is how you get the free
content by supporting us and we are
never going away on the free platforms
at salado's credit.com / moto club or
you could of course enjoy the live show
March 22nd at SMU Idol cutter TOCOM
slash tour enjoy the rest
[Music]
big fan of her next guest I you know I
grew up watching him I grew up as a fan
of his concert here and then I got to
know him there are few people where
that's the case Nick DiPaolo is one Joe
I didn't really watch Joe Rogan's
standup
yeah whole lot because I was in Canada
we can really have access to it but I
watched him I was on Fear Factor noxian
Dennis Prager I listened to on the radio
a lot yeah and this next gentleman Jim
Norton you can file them on the Twitter
at Jim Norton how are you sir I'm good
buddy it's funny on Twitter I was
looking I'm sorry to hear about your
back but it's amazing what like you're
like yeah I hurt my back and people just
immediately I try falling off a scaffold
and your fruit like like their back
injuries are legit and yours was like
you know you're a little [ __ ] cuz you
hurt your back doing something other
than I'm like a man's task right yeah I
know this is true although you know I I
did do it doing a [ __ ] task so it was
it was actually warming up and it was I
didn't respect the warm up weight doing
deadlifts and I was in a rush and so I
skipped a couple warm-up sets and it was
funny was loud enough work and actually
the guy across the gym who hurt your
back I said yeah you mind taking off the
weights and then it's at that rush home
because you're in the eye of the storm
you know before it's upon you so you
wear like a belt when you lift because I
just watched a video the guy from game
of thrones mountain just broke the
deadlift record yeah I think he just
said a world record looked like a little
over a thousand pounds ago thousand no
no no he's probably one hell of
adventure though just that range of
motion just yeah he actually lifted
Peter Dinklage and five of his friends
know I didn't know you know the guy
actually was talking with me about that
today because that was held before by
Eddie hall and Eddie Hall is one of the
few strong men to ever compete in watch
people what are you doing what's wrong
there's actually a film about it called
born strong it's fascinating he was at
this point he had never won strongman he
was competing against the mountains of
East Coast is one guy and Brian Shaw but
he did hold the world record deadlift I
guess until it was broken and he said as
soon as I win world Strongest Man I will
quit and I will lose you know 100
something and he did he won it and then
he walked away because these people yeah
but the mountain is like 6 foot 8 6 foot
9 400 something pounds I think is dead
like those guys well from Iceland to
they're all Icelandic there's
300,000 people in Iceland and all of
them are world strongest men competitors
I don't yeah keep that gene pool small
yes oh yeah I guess so they're all
having sex with each other yeah
yes well weed this Teddy came out today
your third cousin it's fine it just
can't be there for your first cousin it
does not taint the gene pool oh yeah
yeah yeah so listen I know you have your
tour you're next
March 16 to the DCM Pro or as a DC
improv is ocular large 16 yeah Foxwoods
okay and DC improv 22nd to 24th I want
to ask you this because you're obviously
one of the biggest names and stand-up
out there right now when was it can you
remember your first time when you sold
out a venue where people were there for
you oh yeah it was I was just getting on
Opie and Anthony it was a place in
Philadelphia it seats like 500 and it
was called the theatre of the Living
Arts and we went on a rocking party PLA
we said PLA for short that's how all the
rock stars how you know the kids are
into it yeah the Living Arts and I sold
out five shows in a couple of days so
that was the first thing that indicates
good wow this radio thing really is
gonna bring in an audience but it's a
weird it's it's a relief and it's a
pressure like the relief is I know I
just have to be funny I'm not gonna
offend them if they're hoping Anthony
fans and they're there to see me they're
gonna they're probably there to do it
listen to what I have to say but if I
suck they're gonna let me know it
because they're OPN Athenee fans and
they pay to see me right so I knew I had
to be funny but I knew I didn't have to
worry about offending them so it was
kind of a pressure and no pressure at
the same time that's a good way of
describing because that was a first time
for us at Virginia Tech where was a 550
seat and they returned hundreds of
people away and we surprised I was we
actually you know cuz you know the
comedy compression I talked with these
guys about all the time you want people
packed in if it's a room you want them
packed in as tightly as possible so I
had actually roped off the back rows and
the side rows because let's put them in
this pocket sure and it was a bizarre
experience I think that's a good way to
put it you know there's some buy-in so
you know okay they understand where
we're coming from we're not gonna have
to worry about offending them despite
antiphon protesting outside but they're
here for a good time the flip side is we
better be funny you know because they
are here like you said to see us and
it's it changes the whole dynamics I
wonder if you you you've managed to keep
sort of I guess your stand-up chops a
lot of guys get their second specialists
not the same it's not it's not as good I
see that a lot I like my newer ones
better than my own
the ones I'm more comfortable onstage I
just I enjoy them a lot more yeah um it
depends on how long it take it took me a
while to get my first one but I never
stopped to understand them some guys
like just kind of like bit up they they
just they tour on the same hour they
just shot right I'm like what are you
doing you just did that on TV everyone's
gonna go there and know your dumb jokes
that would bore me to tears to it I just
I couldn't do it so right now I'm not
ready for another special exam on this
tour I'm like I'm cycling through this
so much stuff to talk about the topical
stuff just kind of goes back to your
work ethic because that means you know
I've told us to not gauge here because
you know you don't have really the same
experience or spend computer here this
is the I've been bringing that we're
actually doing the full show live the
monologue sketches interactive stuff
with the audience and I said listen
you've got to re-earn it every show the
next show they don't know they don't
know this is wondrous applause they have
no idea starting at point zero but a lot
of comedians lose sight of that that's
one thing that and have to blow smoke
but I've always watched a recent special
like oh wow the quality's actually I
would save I wouldn't say gone up
certainly not gone down it's been
consistently really good that's and
that's really good it's not the case so
with a lot of thank you yeah I mean you
can't the thing is I'm just desperate
like I look at it like any minute
everyone is gonna realize I stink so
it's like III do I do uh my the chip
podcast I do radio I do my gay like I'm
trying to do everything just in case
everything else is taking away honestly
I know you doesn't finish that thought
and so what you just said was I do my
gay and you continued oh that was pretty
that's probably my mind just saying go
ahead out yourself you shared it
completely really um let me ask you are
you a guy and then we'll talk about
stormy Daniels because I'm sure you have
some thoughts let me ask you this are
you a guy who would get always gets
nervous before onstage or are you
someone who's because I've always envied
people who don't um I think I do get
mildly Carson City used to get nervous
like you have to have some like I'm not
nervous Leo no there and I'm not funny
I'm what I'm nervous about is I hope I
don't forget my act I hope like I know
most of the material will work in front
of my audience to have worked it out
enough but I'm like I hope I don't
forget my act like I panic I was going
through this thing years ago where I was
on stage I was on a theater tour and I
was getting like lightheaded I thought I
was gonna vomit on stage and I was at
the Orpheum in Boston I'm physically
holding on to a chair in front of about
2,300 people and
like I'm gonna collapse I'm gonna
collapse and I realized I was just
afraid and I finally just said to myself
you just shut up and collapsed then like
in my head and it went away because I
realized you're gonna faint as Jade is
cagney that's your buddy look ma bottom
of the world after you you would risen
to fame special so you had it okay okay
I was into this no it's actually before
my spell this is 2002 because for the
after Opie and Anthony first got fire
monster rain was my first pressure was
2007 right but I was just scared man and
I didn't know how to say I was scared so
it made it into this physical thing
you're gonna collapse and I just finally
just screamed to myself I just shut up I
was so disgusted with myself then I kind
of snapped me out of it
wow that is incredible you know what
there you go he should do it you should
do like a Jordan Peterson book 12 gems
for life with was Jim Norton stage
fright I think that would help hey what
do you think about the state of comedy
as it relates more so to the
entertainment industry we just saw the
Oscars I don't know who you're obviously
I know you were tight with Jay Leno I
don't know who you're friends with in
the late night department so I want to
get you in trouble but Kimmel was super
super political there yeah turn off for
a lot of people I watched it and it just
seemed so flat and it occurred to me in
2018 comedy certainly as it relates to
what you can see on television thank God
for Netflix and YouTube it's not it's
not very fun anymore
you know somebody raised a good point I
loved your vase when he hosts the Golden
Globes and because he kind of sets out
to ruin their night and somebody pointed
out that you either play to the audience
or you play to the people at home
Ricky plays to the people at home and
Jimmy was playing through the audience I
was actually impressed because I was
surprised he addressed Harvey Weinstein
at all I thought they were gonna cut
totally and just bash Trump and Lenny
went bad slump that's fine as the
president but I thought it was just
gonna be so predictable but I was a
little shocked that they went into it
and they did talk about me too and it's
a tough gig for him too because a lot of
those people might be victims in the
audience who have had like assaults from
producers and not know what to do and do
like he's please want to bomb at the
Oscars and then ruin the fact he's never
gonna get these people on his show like
don't forget he's performing for the
people who come on his show so that's
kind of a tough gig and I have no
audience at home because imagine how
hard I mean we would have been passing
ourselves laughing
if he made you know the Hollywood rape
jokes and it made people in the audience
really uncomfortable you know cutter
Jennifer Garner and she's like she was
one of them we would be laughing at home
but you can't so he has two PS to cater
to them that's really it's kind of like
a total with it with a debate we do
these change my mind segments what you
have to do is identify who you're
talking with is that someone whose mind
can be changed if so you try to and if
it's not if it's like a hardcore leftist
who wants to get us banned from SMU what
you have to do is go okay at this point
over the moment I'm talking to them for
everyone else watching sure yeah I've
long since given up trying to change
people's opinions because it's not my
job as a comedian like you as a comic I
try to be funny and I want to be
original and I want to express my
opinion and if people like it great and
I've had my opinion altered a little bit
listening to comedians you know but I
didn't I I don't like to be spoken at
like my goal was not to go out there and
educate anybody I don't think I'm so
much smarter than the audience that they
need me on stage to educate them
sometimes you change someone's mind
sometimes you don't but you know I think
it's fun to make people laugh at things
that they don't agree with right like to
me that's a great challenge because
whenever I mentioned Trump I don't I
mean I make fun of certain parts but I
don't just go up there and kill them you
know because to me every comic does that
and I don't hate him so I'm not gonna
pretend I hate him if I don't and it's
fun to watch we all went to the Trump
thing I was like the Bush years toward
the end you're like it's not you never
want to know like an entire business
should never have the same political
opinion if the business is open there
should be some who like him and some who
don't and some who think he says good
things and someone thinks what he says
is crap I mean I mean there's certain
guys like James Woods and other guys who
are really all in with him but with
comedy you don't see as many guys like
Nick DiPaolo I mean I I know he's fine
with Trump yeah but a lot a lot of guys
I think even guys that like certain
things he says are afraid of it and
that's the beauty of me is I'll never go
higher than mediocrity so they can't
hurt me what are they gonna take away
the comedy sell it from me I get paid 35
bucks there well yeah exactly and you're
and you're not afraid to go low when
they go high go low you're like Peter
absolutely believe me I will undercut
all the other comedian okay so this I
don't have I have your Twitter where's
the website though for people to go and
check out your tour for the future dates
and Jim Jim Norton com Jim Norton com
Jim Norton
he is going to be uh I've Jordan
Peterson up in front of me at Jim Norton
because some people have the underscore
in a throw and then someone recently has
his - why would you have a - in 2018 and
not use an underscore Jim Norton comm
he's gonna be at the DC improv and we'll
have you back soon brother have a good
time with these shows don't collapse
[Music]
March 22nd SMU Dallas Texas prepares the
greatest show can I come inside guys
beep beep oh wait but it's writing out
here
our AppleCare cover that with it tolik
covers the manufacturer defects as a
clapper loader diligence
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I know what the key is their key is the
webbing oh really this is a get out no
one taught me how to swim I jump up but
I I learned my methods through observing
ducks ducks a child knows going I'm not
getting anywhere thank you Sesame Street
look I said wait there seems to be
webbing hmm did that no I just I just
fixed the riptides problem now your
problem also mallards mate for life
really so long as we're not first
cousins I had to bring back that Jim
Norton bench bureau thank you so much
and by the way we told him that we were
going to be broadcasting live from South
by Southwest next week they kicked us
out they revoked our passes reveal her
what's it took now me and not Kay Jarrod
foreshadowing we won't be broadcasting
live so it's gonna be a normal show next
Thursday and then March 22nd live from
SMU the we kept at Illinois live
broadcasting on campus who knows what
could happen you know the Angeles Oh
mister a little bit different for the
last segment today you just saw her
dancing she has been writing it loud it
was cried her now for the last I want us
is eight months a year you know Nicole
Cooper mm-hmm Nicole how are you doing
well thanks Stephen thank you for being
on the ship no listen for people who
don't know this is actually one of the
have room because it's going to be her
last day at writing atlatl credit today
is her last day and we wanted to see her
off Nicole how long have you been
writing at the web site I'm almost a
year now
yeah coming up on a year okay almost a
year that's right and you came to us
through the golden ticket submissions
for people yeah that was totally kind of
just by chance I was on y'all's website
one day saw the jobs tab and the rest is
history
the rest is history not so much no I
mean it's still it lives on forever and
an archive is true I guess that
technically is its digital history and
for people asking no I did not give you
the boot we are all actually very hard
you're fired
come on the show come on put a smile on
no I were actually really sad that
you're leaving us it took first off
gonna be hard to replace it was a long
time with the Golden Tickets hundreds of
submissions was totally blind by the way
and you just happen to be the the best
person who applied but um you are
leaving us and I don't want to I don't
want to steal I don't want to say steal
your thunder I'm on a pain pill today
too so listen it's okay at this point
anyone's paying attention there's some
bye and they know who you are we can
explain to them why it is that you're
leaving us at this point so soon yeah
yeah so I'm actually really sick that's
why I'm laying on a pillow instead of in
a proper office chair I thought it was a
thing people were using pillows at that
time you know just lounging yeah exactly
well you look fine you look you still
look great on the sky better than me
yeah that's right whatever so so yeah
I'm really sick I have a late stage Lyme
disease Borrelia burgdorferi is the
technical term and it's just been
getting worse and worse and I was just
like I need to leave louder with Crowder
before my writing starts being affected
because I've been really really sick
before I kind of bounce back but I'm
kind of back on the downhills so like I
know my Bucky and I know you know when
I'm gonna get worse and I was just like
I need to just step back you know
because you guys deserve the best people
to be working with you and I know that I
can't be performing at my best deserve
some some rest and recovery time and I
was trying to read up on this I know
everyone knows Lyme disease and ticks I
wasn't really familiar with this and
honestly I didn't know that you were
especially going on campus I don't I
don't want to reveal anything but we
wheelchair-bound that was kind of a
suprise when Courtney told me that a
while back I didn't even know and I felt
like a real-ass for not knowing I should
have asked um what is this exactly
because most people are not familiar
with it yeah so everyone's you know
familiar with acute Lyme disease as you
said it's something that you can get
from a tick bite also mosquitoes and
spiders can carry it however if you're
not treated right away after you get
bitten and infected it can turn into
chronic Lyme or late stage Lyme and that
basically is just these little bacteria
there there's spiral-shaped and they can
get into any
where in your body and so they love the
nervous system and attacking the nervous
system so mine got into my brain and my
spinal fluid and so I have problems with
seizures cognitive difficulties heart
difficulties just started having thyroid
stuff it's affecting my blood counts now
so it can really just wreak havoc on
your whole body I have friends who are
on feeding tubes and yeah I know you
imagine there's some controversy I guess
surrounding the idea of some some people
say it doesn't it doesn't exist and
again I don't I don't know anything
about anything when it comes to Lyme I
got checked my okay no tick I'm good
what's the controversy was the line so
the controversy is well first of all as
you said a lot of doctors and people
don't believe in Lyme they don't think
it's a thing just because there hasn't
been a lot of research up until now
there's a lot of stuff coming out of
Johns Hopkins Duke University and
Stanford where they're finally saying
hey this is a real thing these patients
need help and these patients need
treatment the biggest debate right now
however is what the best way to treat
Lyme patients is antibiotics have always
been the way to go but it can be really
invasive because a lot of patients have
to go on IV antibiotics well I think
kind of people throw the baby out with
the bathwater like Nucky Jer and I
talked about that what's colitis
everyone says you know I have colitis I
have Crohn's and they blame murder they
blamed gluten like well gluten gluten is
the thing and so it just sort of became
you know naturopath Rizzo
okay avoid gluten and so people do I
feel lethargic there's a chronic Lyme so
some of that gets tossed under the
umbrella but actual neurological
obviously with you it's it's it's not I
feel kind of bloated you've had the
blood work and in been on antibiotics
for a while I know yeah most definitely
and so the standard Lyme test that's
given today for acute Lyme disease it's
not accurate it's only six sixty percent
accurate the most recent study has shown
and so there's new tests that have been
developed and they picked up on mine
from those news tests new tests but it
took them eight years to find hey listen
don't worry about the word flub you're
doing better than me right now thanks to
hoppers tramadol
should be a sponsor right now to talk
about it by the way exact same exact
same pills as the vet described to me
also the vet is also a liar prescribed
there we go looks I don't have Lyme I'm
just a [ __ ] by the way people and the
reason we want to I wanted to bring you
one was because I know it's hard to get
in to see specialists and neurologists
and people who might notice feel put it
this way whether people out there
wherever they line up on Lyme disease a
chronic Lyme disease are this idea or
not you know you haven't these
neurological issues I know you need help
and I know that it's been tough you know
there's a long waiting line with with
specialists so please anyone out there
if you can help her email Nicole at La
Rose credit com that's Nicole with an H
right Nicole with an H at La Rose credit
and I wanted to bring you onto it Nicole
you know because we've talked about this
like very very few layoffs in this
company and obviously the only reason
the layoffs that have happened have ever
happened is because it affected
everybody else in the team and you know
you came to us blind with a with a
golden ticket application and we've
always kind of done these sort of
employee assessments and in Courtney and
Jared nine specifically court and the
website of always going whenever we came
to you were like well she just she's
particularly got a great attitude such a
positive attitude such a can-do attitude
and your student and you've always been
so grateful and we've been grateful to
you and you've been so consistent and to
the point where I honestly didn't know
that your health was as bad as it was
because people wouldn't know it to
communicate with you and you've helped
love other people so I wanted to just do
what we can to to get you some some help
here but you've been right to us thank
you so much Steven I've enjoyed working
here so much it is so hard for me to
walk away you guys are amazing you work
so hard and just produce amazing
material so it's an honor to worked here
well it was it's been a pleasure for us
to have you work for us and of course if
you recover you always have a welcome
spot to to come back and you know I
think it's important for people to see
out there a lot of people who they're
saying you know we've talked about this
people who work for me are the first
people I think of when I get up often
the last people before I go to sleep
outside of my wife constantly we've been
talking about this constantly been
thinking about these things and
constantly we want to make sure that
people are taken care of that's why we
have very closely knit team oh we could
just hired a day raters like other
companies do and pay them the lowest
amount to
do clickbait which we've seen a lot of
sites fall by the wayside but I think a
big part of it is people like Courtney
and Casey and Brautigan and Corey and
yourself and of course Jared and
everyone who works here I think people
can sense a difference and people can
sense a difference a big part of these
sweepstakes and big reason you went
through is like I said there's an
attitude and the way you treat other
people the way you work with other
people it's it's been a real blessing to
a lot of us and you know we're really
sad to see you go but I really hope that
someone out there hearing this can can
give you a hand and hopefully some
people also won't listen not all
employers employees it's not the relate
it's not the Scrooge McDuck no you know
we actually we actually care I certainly
care and sometimes sometimes it's tough
sometimes sometimes I feel too deeply
but um in this case it's it's a I'm
gonna miss you I'm gonna miss you guys
too
a lot well listen we're always a phone
call and a skype away you know hopefully
gets that's nicole with an H Nicole at
lotto with better calm we're gonna see
you guys next week
please keep Nicole in your thoughts and
prayers and send her any help or anyone
who you think might be able to help
Nicole we love you genuinely I love you
you say it say it be a man I love you
Nicole and we'll certainly be in touch
talking with you and everyone else you
want it you want to play us out here
Nicole tell them I'm gonna see them next
week oh yeah thank you all for joining
us today and we'll see you next week
there you go she should have my job
[Music]